in the next 40 minutes or less we will
talk to you about how to create a
service machine learning system to
classify text using Amazon Web Services
and poison there are three of us I'm
Veronica and I'm gonna talk about
classification text classification in
general and why you might want to use a
taxonomy and I'm Stewart and I'm gonna
talk to you about how to use a REST API
to create your text classification
system hi I'm David and I'll talk about
creating a inaudible workflow for
training and deploying a service
classifier and then to finish I will
talk a little bit about what you might
do to improve your classifier results
okay so classification namely text
classification has many use cases in the
world the one I'm gonna be talking about
today is news classification so applying
descriptive metadata to news textual
news content and the reason I'm using
this example is because we're we work
for The Associated Press and we are in
the news business we produce and
distribute news content globally on a
daily basis but we also have a news
taxonomy and a tagging system that we
use to apply tags to all the content
flowing through our pipeline so text
classification why would this online
newspaper for example want to have tags
on their content well for one it would
help improve their search the navigation
it would help with their recommendation
system for example it helps this
newspaper aggregate and route their
content into the various subject
verticals such as your sports section
your business section this article that
you're seeing here about the u.s.
women's team taking their first step
towards Rio Olympics got all of these
topics applied that you can maybe see up
above and each of them can resolve into
a landing page that aggregates all that
content that was also tagged with that
same topic tags are also great for just
bility so this online newspaper on this
article you see there two athletes
featured Jordan Larsen and Kelsey
Robinson and you can imagine that maybe
alongside this article you might have
some additional information about these
athletes that I use or might want to see
so maybe what's her name Jordan Larson's
home town maybe the sport she plays for
the team she plays with all of this
additional information can be taken
taken from the tag itself okay how do we
do that well we use a taxonomy so this
is you're looking at a small tiny piece
of our AP News taxonomy this is for our
sporting events and you can see that our
taxonomy has a hierarchical structure
has semantic relationships between the
terms so down at the bottom there's the
2016 Rio games it has sibling
relationships to all of its siblings
there as a parent of Summer Olympic
Games and it that itself has a parent of
Olympic Games we also store additional
information about each of our taxonomy
terms so properties relationships other
terms attributes such as what you're
seeing here so this is actually an RDF
turtle format representation of our
taxonomy term for Jordan Larson who's
the athlete saw two slides ago and you
can see she has various relationships to
other terms attributes properties such
as her associated States here her
hometown the sports she plays for her
some other biographical information
about her okay so great so say you built
a taxonomy you've decided which
properties attributes relationships you
want to store about each term in your
taxonomy how do you then apply that
taxonomy to your text well one way to do
it is manually this is actually a photo
of a New York of the New York Times
press room in 1942 so there wasn't a lot
of happy news in
19:42 but this guy let's say he's
writing an article about Pan Am's first
round-the-world flight scheduled in 1942
this was a historic event right before
he's ready to publish the article he
might go into his content management
system and apply some relevant tags
manually well that's great but what if
you have a ton more data what if you're
producing you know hundreds and
thousands of articles a day this process
won't scale for your system so you might
want to apply your taxonomy in an
automatic way so one way to do that is
to use a rules based classifier to
automatically apply your texana me to
text this is actually what we do at The
Associated Press we have a team of
taxonomist and specialized editors who
write these boolean semantic rules um
that look a little bit like the one here
you're seeing for Hurricane Harvey and
we like this way of applying text on me
to test text at the AP it works for us
for several reasons one of them being
that you know we have a lot of breaking
news and as a story is breaking and
developing we don't have a ton of data
about that story yet we don't have a lot
of articles published about it yet but
we have the need to get that descriptive
tag on that content quickly so this
rules based system allows us to fairly
quickly write a semantic role that
starts tagging that content as it's
being produced okay but not every use
case has this need right to get that tag
on the content really quickly not
everybody has a team of specialized
editors to write these roles so you know
but what if what if you don't have those
things but you have a ton of data well
um the other way you could of course
apply your taxonomy automatically is to
use a statistical classifier so in this
case you would feed your training data
to your tag to your training engine
which would then spit out a trained
bottle
that you can use to tag new content with
and at this point I'm going to hand it
over to Stuart it's gonna talk more
about that thanks Marc
so as veronica was explaining The
Associated Press we have our own tagging
system our own taxonomy that we apply to
news content through our rules-based
system and in fact we also offer that as
a service to people so through a system
called our AP metadata services through
a REST API you can send us your tank
your text content and we'll
automatically apply the relevant tags
and properties from our taxonomy but
what we found is that although that's
great and works really well for things
like breaking news and it's very
comprehensive for the news domain some
customers want to have more depth in
particular areas that we don't cover so
we added a way a REST API to our AP MS
system our metadata services system to
be able to create your own taxonomy and
to be able to apply it to content and
it's really this sort of very simple
four-step REST API then showing up here
so step one you create your tags and
taxonomy so you say these are the these
are the important items that I want to
tag for and these are the Associated
properties that I'd like to apply to my
content you then create training sets so
you assemble regreat examples for each
of your tags you feed that into the into
the classification engine that generates
our classifier for you a tagger and then
at the end of it you've got an API that
will let you feed in brand new articles
and get back the tags and properties
that you want to apply so just to
re-emphasize that let's pretend that you
want to create a classifier for dragons
dragons not a topic that ap colors so so
yeah you love the AP taxonomy but you
want to go beyond that because you've
got lots of documents that feature
dragons so step one is you create your
taxonomy your list of dragons and the
associated properties creating a
taxonomy is really very hard
so I recommend you do what I did which
is to take somebody else's taxonomy in
this case I found one on screen crushed
comm which is a list of dragons
cinematic dragons in fact then so you've
got your tags you've got your properties
that you want to associate with each of
your concepts these of your tags you
create your training set so you assemble
all of your example data for each of
your tags each of your concepts so you
want to tag for you feed that into the
engine to generate a classifier and then
at the end of it you've got an API that
will let you tag new new documents to
apply both the APS taxonomy in this case
but also your brand new dragon taxonomy
as well and now David is gonna tell us a
bit more about how that's actually done
right so Stuart has given us an overview
of the general classifier service and
I'm going to talk in detail about the
part of the workflow where we actually
do the training and deploying over doing
it all with Amazon Web Services and and
along the way I'll try to highlight some
of the problem areas and talk about how
we resolve those issues so if you're
interested in doing something similar
maybe we can save you some time so let's
follow on with that example we have a
user whose wants to augment our news
taxonomy with a text on with about
dragons they have created their taxonomy
of dragons using the tags API and then
they've associated those tags with
example documents using the training
sets API now they're ready to create
their classifier so this is the workflow
that we came up with
I'm sure there's any number of ways you
could do this but this is what we're
doing and I'm gonna go through once kind
of quickly and then we'll go back again
through it with more detail so that we
begin the user will submit their
training set ID to our classifiers API
endpoint and then we're using a service
called step functions so you essentially
process that user request and ultimately
trigger auto scaling and auto scaling
will create a machine instance in the
cloud on which we can do our training
since we need to have
a machine that can stay online for some
time to complete our training process so
once the machine comes up and the worker
is started you can see in the worker
column the activities that it will go
through so it will begin by downloading
the sorry will begin by downloading the
training data using our training sets
API and then we have some static files
that we've kept in s3 we have the
software dependencies for that code as
well as the template code for the
classifier itself the thing will
actually load the model and and apply it
to the incoming documents then once we
have all those files in place we can
begin training and we're using Python
work here at PI data so of course you're
using Python and we're using
scikit-learn but you could substitute an
intensive flow here if you wished but
the results of that training process
should be the trained model and the
taxonomy which you're saving and then
we'll pull all that stuff together into
a single zip file and essentially deploy
that to AWS lambda using an application
called serverless framework and the
result will be this classifier which is
itself an athiest lambda function which
will accept document load the model
apply by that model get back the tag IDs
their probabilities enrich those IDs
with the labels and metadata about those
tags that we just we've created using
the taxonomy API and then return that to
the user so if you're unfamiliar with
lambda this is a service that
essentially allows us to run code in the
cloud without having to worry about
servers there are servers involved there
just were outsourcing that worried to
somebody else Amazon or Microsoft or
Google and this code is essentially
inactive most the time and it's
activated through some event and in our
case that event is an API call this
service approach is appealing to us
because in the news industry we might
have a considerable amount of text
classification work to do after our
breaking news event but on a slow news
day at 2:00 in the morning we might have
less work to do and in which case we
don't need to have a fleet of servers
online all the time just waiting for
requests that might not come so what do
we need to create our lambda class
fire well we need our code that will
load the model said and format the
results to return to the user when we
create our lambda function we need to
provide the dependencies for that code
so we're using scikit-learn to train our
model so we obviously need psyche at and
employ that model we also knew those
artifacts that are produced by the
training process we need the trained
model and the taxonomy and on sort of a
administrative level or lambda function
needs permission to access other AWS
services so if it needs to login error
it needs permissions to access logs if
you need to download or upload data to
s3 need those permissions as well and
finally we need an API endpoint so our
user can actually post a document
somewhere and get back the
classification results all right so now
we'll go back to the beginning and add
in some of those details that I skipped
over so go back to the party process
that user requested and scale up to
create the training machine instance so
as I said we're using the service step
functions this is I guess a relatively
new service from Amazon and it helps us
basically coordinate a bunch of Micra
services into a single workflow and it
gives you this nice sort of visual
workflow tool and you can see the
examples on the page here so you can
kind of watch your data flow through
your application and it's sort of
helpful when you have a lot of different
little functions so on the left here
this is kind of where we're at today
this really simple sort of linear
workflow where we get the request in we
do some validation of the training set
and then we hit this training step which
will actually trigger the auto scaling
policy which will create the machine
instance that we'll need to do our
training we could actually just directly
create a machine as since for every
training request but this would probably
lead to a proliferation of servers in
the cloud and to get their expensive
auto scaling lets us essentially do that
parallel prostates processing but also
set a maximum number of machines were
willing to create so we can control our
costs a bit and I haven't said much
about the machine learning aspect
because what we have is very simple it's
the same sort of machine learning
pipeline every time
but looking ahead we think step
functions might be the place where you
would add that complexity so you can see
sort of a hypothetical workflow on the
right where we evaluate several
algorithms and evaluate the results to
take the best candidate moving right
along
um could talk a bit about machinist as
machine instances and the training and
deploying process so ec2 that's the
service that from Amazon compute
capacity in the cloud and when you first
start working with ec2 you will have to
select a machine image it was
essentially the kind of server you want
to create in the cloud you could just
select a baseline machine image is sort
of like a Linux machine and then
downloads I could learn or whatever you
want but we're actually recommending
that you create your own machine image
and register it so you can reuse it this
will obviously speed up the process of
getting that machine online so you can
actually start your training it's also
gonna ensure that there's a parity
between the software used to train your
model and the software you use to load
and employ that model and the little
dragon there is to remind me that this
is one of those things I didn't realize
and I had trained my scikit-learn model
with an older version of Sai kit and
then tried to load it with a newer
version which gives warning sometimes
errors if you're lucky all right so
another little dragon point here
maybe OS lambda gives you only so much
disk space for you to store your code
and all its dependencies it's a 250
megabytes uncompressed
total you probably haven't spent a lot
of time looking at how much space do
scikit-learn takes up on your hard drive
but it's considerable and actually use
if you kind of like start googling
lambda and scikit-learn this is sort of
like the number one issue that's
discussed it's like how can I get so I
could learn down to the size where I can
actually create a lambda motion with it
thankfully there are other smart people
in the world and I can just copy their
work so there's this really great
library SK learn build lambda which will
emulate the environment that your lambda
function is invoked and it will
download scikit-learn and it will just
strip out all the files that we don't
need and then zip it up and the result
is the dependencies if that's an
appropriately-sized
file also if you want to use tensorflow
instead that's actually a nice article
from the BBC about tensorflow and lamb
down what they did to create a slim down
dependency zip and I did not link to it
here so the result of your training
process will be you know your your
dynamically generated files the model
and the taxonomy and also the sort of
static files that we stored in s 3 which
is our dependencies that we have spent
all this time slimming down and our sort
of template classifier code which is the
thing that loads the model and returns a
results and that's always the same so we
merge those together into one deployment
package zip and we can deploy it so this
is also an automated part of the process
and we are using this application
service framework to make this easier
service framework you haven't
encountered it yet
essentially it lets you specify your
cloud architecture and I would say
relatively few lines of template code
and you can see an example on the right
here it's less than 20 miles of the ML
this is a description of one of our
classifiers and I've highlighted some of
the pieces that we talked about earlier
on the lambda slide so the role here is
related to the permissions our lambda
will be granted when it's activated the
package artifact refers to the zip that
we spent all this time creating
ourselves and the event section here and
an HTTP path this is the API endpoint
that will create a function so this is
gonna make a lot easier for us to create
that classifier
also since serverless framework will
associate all these resources with a
single stack it's gonna make it a lot
easier for us to delete that classifier
in the future if we need to deprecated
it for some reason I'm talking a lot
about Amazon Web Services because that's
kind of what we use at the AP right now
but serve this framework will work with
Azure and Google so if you prefer
another vendor you can still use this
approach and then I guess one last
mention about the zip artifact
usually when you use in a service
swimmer you essentially let it build the
deployment package that for you
in our case we have this really special
need to do it ourselves and in that case
we can override the usual behavior with
her package artifact reference here
alright so we've arrived at the end of
the workflow here and we have our lambda
based classifier I just want to close
with a few notes about working with
lambda it's been around long enough that
there are considerable complaints and
one of those complaints has to do with
cold starts and this is the issue where
lambda function if it's been active
connected for some period of time and
that suddenly you tell it to do
something there's a sort of slower
startup time and then once you're using
it again that slow startup time issue
does go away but this is problematic
enough for some people if you are those
some people there is some evidence that
allocating more memory to your lambda
function will help with this and this is
a simple configuration change you make
when you create your lambda function you
can also take a more drastic approach
and just have some scheduled tasks just
pinging that lambda function every 30
minutes just to keep it active but this
is gonna incur all these unnecessary
costs it's kind of the whole point of us
going this psorbos service route us to
avoid that seem route to a few nights me
finally in all my examples I've shown
i've been keeping our trained model on
our taxonomy with our lambda function
code this is convenient for us and it's
possible because we're sort of just
augmenting our much larger rules based
taxonomy so are these the tax summaries
were creating this way or fairly small
and we can sort of include them without
flower hitting those lambda size limits
but if you have a much larger taxonomy
you're trained model is also gonna be
much larger and then you're not gonna be
able to keep it with your lambda code
you're gonna have to keep it in s3 and
then download it when the function is
invoked and I just wanted to point out
if you are going this route that lambda
environment that container is reused as
the function is called over over again
so it's possible that if you've
previously downloaded your model to the
temp directory that it is still there
when the function is invoked again so
you should just wrap your download
function in a little check to see if the
file exists first and that will also
save you some startup time I say I'm
gonna turn it back over to Veronica
again so we can talk more about how to
improve the text Hospital Thanks
okay thanks David so David just
described how to build a text classifier
with AWS and scikit-learn and the goal
of course of building such a text
classifiers to tag new content with your
class if I are hopefully accurately so
what can you do on the one hand to
measure how accurate your your model is
and on the other hand what can you do to
fix it if it's not up to par so there
depending on what your model is and what
your system is clearly there are many
different ways to get at metrics many
different metrics you could get in the
first place and many different things
you could do to improve but I'm just
going to talk about a small subset of
those that we would potentially apply to
our use case using this text classifier
that we just built okay so one way one
standard way to measure results of your
model is to use a confusion matrix which
basically is just a table that can show
you where your models getting confused
and you're looking at one version of a
confusion matrix here this one happens
to be for a theoretical model that is
trained to distinguish between ido
eagles doves and pigeons and just to
walk you through briefly what you're
seeing I have a hundred articles that I
know are about eagles going down the
right hand side column there a hundred
articles I know are about doves and a
hundred I know are about pigeons so if I
then take this set and see how my
classifier predicts for these three
classes I can see how how it performs so
if you go we go across the Eagles row
there of the hundred Eagles articles it
predicted ninety-five of them were about
Eagles so that's pretty good
moving down to doves of a hundred of
articles it thought 72 of them were
about deaths and 25 were about pigeons
so not so great in similar situation
along the pigeons row down there where
it thought 75 of the hundred pigeon
articles were about pigeons but it also
thought 23 of them were about death so
clearly something is happening there in
that lower quadrant and if I then take
some everything up along this green
diagonal I can get a accuracy
measurement for my entire model which in
this case is 80% but well that's
interesting it's not going to give you a
lot of information about the class how
your classes did individually so it's
not going to tell me that my model
actually did pretty great for Eagles but
it's having issues around doves and
pigeons so what you do want to do is
really measure get some metrics around
the performance per class of your model
so this confusion matrix can be expanded
to get at those more detailed metrics
per class and you want to at least get
the precision and recall precision being
number of correct predictions divided by
the total number in the data set and
recall number of correct positive
predictions divided by the total number
of positives and you want to get those
per class so so you've gotten your
metrics around your model see how it's
doing and you want to improve it what
can you do to improve these results well
for one you can take a look at your
training data and make sure that what
you've fed your model in the first place
was correctly tagged right your this is
what you're teaching your model on so
you the quality of that set matters so I
might go back and look and see maybe
some of my pigeon articles were actually
tagged with as doves and vice versa so I
would correct those and maybe three
trained quantity matters too clearly but
only if it's correctly tagged so
throwing more data at your model to
train it is not gonna be any good if
that if that data is not correctly
tagged in the first place looking at my
my specific example I might want to add
some more evidence for my model about
pigeons and about doves so that maybe it
can learn to distinguish the difference
between the two a little bit better and
then you do want to make sure that your
training sets are fairly balanced across
across classes as much as you can so at
the outset if I had given my model a
thousand Eagles articles but only fifty
each of doves and pigeons well maybe
that's why it's not learning the
difference so well another thing you
want to look at to see if you can
improve results of your model is the
taxonomy itself that you used so does it
have you know clean semantics are they
are as your taxonomy semantically sound
are you using distinct concepts between
your notes in your taxonomy are you are
using the correct relationships between
them so in in the Dubs
eagles pigeons example are those three
classes all siblings of each other do
they all have a parent of the birds does
it make sense you know if your texana me
makes semantic sense your model will
will be less confused and also you want
to avoid overlapping concepts between
nodes so if you've done everything you
could to help your model distinguish
between doves and pigeons but it's still
having a hard time well you might want
to take a look at the semantics there
and do our doves and pigeons really
semantically that distinct if they're
not you might consider merging those two
terms into one and streamlining your
taxonomy that way okay so those are just
a few things you could try to improve
your results and at this point I'm gonna
hand it back over to Stuart to say thank
you very much
any questions yes yeah so the question
is essentially what is the process and
is it really as simple as I showed in my
four steps and so so the answer is yes
it is that simple where we we just
provided a pretty simple it designed to
be very simple API a lot of the
complexity comes though in designing
your taxonomy and assembling your
training set and so on so so the API
itself is very simple you say this these
are the tags I want here's the training
data make me a classifier and they're
classified documents so super simple
that way but in fact they the
engineering of the taxonomy is difficult
as Veronica was talking about to get the
taxonomy right and decide what you want
picking out the right training data
that's difficult to so yes it's really
simple but but is there's a lot of scope
here for data scientists to do tons of
work
okay so the question is could we could
we use lambda itself so the service
technology to create a train model we
actually did try that but there's a time
limit on how long you can run a lambda
for possibly at AWS reinvent right now
they're changing that I don't know but I
think it's it's five minutes yeah
especially five minutes so it's rare
that you're gonna have a system that you
can train in five minutes or less and
the lambda limit is if you exceed the
five minutes then it's gone so you can't
like pick it up and continue so that's
why we worked out a way to spin up ec2
boxes and just let them run in order to
do that
so so you are you asking if if you could
speed up the training process by using
more cores is that okay right so the
question is could you make that training
process parallel so that it was run
shorter so I don't think so not with
certainly not with the scikit-learn
because it's effectively age you know
fit you know you just run it and it and
it keeps on going until until it stops
so you can't really parallel lies that
so no I'm not aware of anybody else
doing that with scikit-learn it could be
that with other other libraries you may
be able to parallel why's that
yes yes right so the question is surely
an article news articles about more than
one thing and yet we showed like a
really simple confusion matrix where
each document really just belonged to
one category and so yes that's right so
we didn't have so that confusion matrix
yes so so for our news taxonomy that a
peas new taxonomy week a document can be
about hundreds of things potentially
because we classify for people places
companies organizations and subjects so
very many topics however we do we do cry
we do measure for each for each term we
do measure whether or not it was correct
or not
so I guess hmm I don't know
if you have a more of an answer that you
could say into the microphone yeah so
you're right new specification is
definitely a multi-label classification
problem and our rules based tagging
engine really doesn't have so many
issues with that as far as a machine
learning solution to that that's that's
kind of not what this sort of workflow
is for it it's it's I mean it could be
if we were capable of creating a really
smart hierarchical multi-label machine
learning classifier if people have
awesome ideas about that I'd love to
hear them but yeah so we're sort of our
use case as a customer who's just
augmenting our existing taxonomy with a
handful of terms that are missing that
they think are missing and so our hope
is that in those cases we can sort of
have more of a multi-class than a multi
label kind of solution and then that
will be acceptable we have we have so as
we've said that we our main
classification systems actually
rules-based where we have people who
write the rules and of course we've been
asked well couldn't you just replace
that with a no statistical or other kind
of machine
and so we've experimented with that and
so far the answer is no it doesn't seem
to work for the granularity and
precision that we need and for the size
of the taxonomy and they how
conceptually similar some of the things
are don't know if that really answers
your question but David you wanna answer
the question was a bad luck I would yeah
no it's a good answer there's actually
this really helpful I we found called
wasn't bogging for humans or something
and it's it's just a command-line thing
that helps you kind of look at those
cloud box logs everything is logged with
lambda but it's just really hard to find
the thing that you're looking for it so
you can you can set up metrics for like
alarms for when there are errors and
then you there's all sort of stuff you
can do it's really complicated perhaps
yeah yeah I mean I think that what we
found is that lambdas great in all kinds
of ways but really primitive for being
able to see what's going on or
understand things so there are ways that
you can simulate
the lambda environment locally it's
still really hard question of it yeah
[Music]
okay so the second question first so
zapper versus serve Allah so zapper is
another library for all sort of helping
you do these service deployments we
looked at zapper and we looked at
service and we found that at the time
service had that was the easiest to use
and had the most functions Sam so if you
want if you're happy with AWS Sam is a
relatively new library from Amazon
that's meant to help you with
automatically two points to their lamda
system so the first question I think was
about a different kind of a workflow and
I'm not right yes yes
I said alright so so I think the
question is could you do more of an
iterative workflow where you sort of do
a so yes so the answer is yes so we've
talked about having a a weak classifier
and then running it against more
examples and then seeing like okay where
does it go wrong and then feeding those
bad examples or the misclassified things
into the training sets and then
regenerating the classifier as well so
yes I think that's that's a pretty good
we think that's a good workflow to and I
think I'm being told that we're out of
time so so thanks very much
[Applause]